as one of the few comedians with real
legitimate musical Talent have you ever
done the goddamn Comedy Jam and if so
have you ever considered playing one of
your own songs I've done it many times I
was supposed to do the very first one
they ever did and I couldn't do it I was
I was living in La at the time I was
booked for it and I got stuck out in New
York I forget why I was in New York but
I couldn't leave and I called Josh and
said I'm sorry I can't do that show
where you want us to sing the songs or
whatever he didn't have a name for it
yet and then so I did the second one and
on the second one I did Power of Love by
Huey Lewis in the news and and then I
was I've been a part of it ever since I
do the Comedy Jam all the time but no I
would never do my own like if there were
some like
demand for it I would do it like it
would be an about it but like no
I wouldn't do it like like
I should do that yeah that seems awfully
indulgent yeah